vamos a seguir con los exámenes de
cálculo ap pasemos a la pregunta 2 del
examen de 2008 tipo veces aquí copie la
tabla que nos dan en el problema el
resto del problema lo voy a leer y vamos
a ver qué onda el problema dice los
boletos para un concierto se comenzaron
a vender en el tiempo de igual a 0 justo
a mediodía fueron tan pedidos que se
acabaron en 9 horas el número de
personas que estaban en la fila al
tiempo t se puede modelar con una
función l l de aquí que es dos veces
diferenciable así este renglón muestra
la cantidad de personas que estaban en
cada momento y aquí es el tiempo este
está igual a 0 t igual a 1 y 9 es las 9
de la noche todos los boletos se
vendieron a las 9 también nos dicen que
la función es dos veces diferenciables
esto nos dice varias cosas de la función
por ejemplo la primera es que es
continua pero más aún como es dos veces
diferenciables su derivada también es
continua entonces es una función bien
suave sale vamos a las preguntas las
preguntas dicen lo siguiente el inciso a
que es el primero dice lo siguiente
a ver voy a poner con este color y dice
usar la información en la tabla para
estimar sabes que mejor voy a copiar y
pegar el enunciado a ver le voy a dar
copiar entonces ahora me voy aquí al
programa le pico edición pegar ahí está
lo voy a acomodar un poco ahí está un
poquito más abajo a lo mejor no lo
alcanzas a leer pero yo si lo leo de
todas formas dice usa la información de
la tabla para estimar la razón en la
cual cambia la cantidad de personas en
la fila a las 5 30 de la tarde acá en la
tabla no nos dicen qué pasa a las 5 y
media así que tenemos que hacer algunas
estimaciones muestra tus operaciones e
indica las unidades que se utilizan para
entonces quieren que estudiemos la razón
en la cual cambia el número de personas
en la fila como hacemos esto la tabla
solamente tiene algunos puntos de la
función el dt y no nos dan la
información cerca de 5.5 sin embargo lo
más cerca que podemos acercarnos de cada
lado es por aquí pues tenemos
información acerca del tiempo 4 y del
tiempo 7
entonces podemos encontrar un buen
estimado encontrando la razón de cambio
entre estos dos puntos para hacer esto
vamos a tener que hacer una fracción y
recordar un poco como le hacíamos para
calcular ciertas pendientes a ver vamos
a escribir por aquí abajo
cómo se calcula la pendiente voy a
utilizar notación que se usa en cálculo
es decir voy a poner una delta mayúscula
voy a poner delta de l entre delta de t
y ahora tengo que indicar que es en 5.5
déjame poner el igual por aquí y voy a
poner 5.5 aquí en el subíndice va en vez
de un igual puedes poner una
aproximadamente igual o como prefieras
ahora sí vamos a calcularlo nos queda el
de 7 menos el de 4 dividido entre 7
menos 4 ok justo eso de ahí es cómo
cambia la función entre cómo cambiar la
variable entonces el de 7 es 150
luego hay que restar 126 y tenemos que
dividir
en 374 vamos a hacer las operaciones 150
menos 126
a ver eso es lo mismo que 50 menos 26 50
menos 20 nos da 30 y menos otros seis
nos da 24
vamos al denominador tenemos que dividir
entre 7 4 y 7 menos cuatro estrés va el
cambio es 24 tercios pero eso podemos
simplificar lo 24 entre 3 da a 8
ok también nos piden las unidades verdad
que nos piden las unidades de esta razón
de cambio en el numerador tenemos
personas entonces aquí le pongo personas
y tengo que dividir en el denominador
que son horas
entonces el mejor estimado o más bien
nuestro mejor estimado es acercándonos
en cuatro y siete hacemos la diferencia
de la función dividimos entre la
diferencia de los tiempos y nos quedan
ocho personas por hora
ok vamos a ir a la parte ve voy a borrar
un poco esto va a tener mucho espacio
y voy a copiar y pegar el nuevo
enunciado a ver ahí va
vamos a copiar y pegar lo voy a poner
por aquí dice usa una suma trapezoidal
con 3 sub intervalos a ver deja ver si
puedo hacer el enunciado un poco más
grande a ver lo estiro por acá
a ver algo así vamos a ver qué chin
ahora quedó muy flaca la letra no sabes
qué mejor lo voy a poner normal y lo leo
para para que sepas qué dice dice lo
siguiente a ver dice usa una suma
trapezoidal con tres sub intervalos para
estimar el promedio de cuántas personas
estuvieron esperando boletos durante las
primeras cuatro horas de la venta aunque
el problema hable de trapecios la forma
más rápida de hacer este problema es sin
hacer dibujos pero ahorita para
explicarte de dónde vienen mis cuentas
voy a graficar la función ya en el
examen puedes ahorrarte mucho tiempo
saltando de la figura déjame pensar cómo
lo voy a hacer para graficarlo no sé si
poner todo o solo hasta te iguala 4
mejor si dibujo todo puede ayudarnos
para los siguientes incisos entonces voy
a poner mis dos ejes
y ya está el segundo eje voy a poner las
flechitas
y vamos a marcar aquí los puntos para el
tiempo 1 2
4 creo que es la idea verdad 5 6 7 8 y 9
y ahora tenemos que pasar los puntos
pero pero déjame etiquetar los ejes
primero levante y el dt en el horizontal
este y en el vertical va el dt
y entonces pues vamos a poner algunas
marquitas en el eje l dt para poner los
puntos aquí voy a poner pues a ver los
puntos llegan como a menos de 200
entonces le pongo 200 aquí a la mitad
que queda más o menos a esta altura es
100 aquí a la mitad entre 100 y 200 650
y aquí va a ser 50 ok entonces ahora sí
vamos a poner cada uno de los puntos
vamos a graficar los entrego al acero
tenemos 120 personas entonces es como
por ahí entre igual a uno es 156 más o
menos por ahí párate igual a 33 verdad
no 23 es 176 nos queda un punto a esta
altura luego vamos a igual a 4 de igual
a 4 es aquí y tenemos 126 personas es un
poquito más arriba que te iguala 0
es más o menos por ahí párate igual a 7
es 150 es algo por ahí luego te iguala 8
tenemos 80 personas más o menos por ahí
y te iguala 9 tenemos 0 personas ojalá
sea porque todos consiguieron sus
boletos bueno vamos a conectar estos
puntos con líneas rectas le voy a poner
así luego a este y luego a este me
siento como jugando uniendo puntos aquí
y luego bajamos al
pero listo ya tenemos estos puntos
gráfica 2 en aquí en nuestro dibujo
sabemos que la verdadera función el dt
no va a tener estas esquinas porque es
diferenciable de hecho es dos veces
diferenciable va a ser más suave en
estos puntos no podemos tomarlas
no podemos tomar las derivadas porque
pues por ejemplo aquí tenemos una
pendiente que es positiva y luego
cambiar repentinamente a una pendiente
negativa entonces ahí no podríamos
derivar la función pero bueno regresando
al problema dice usa una suma
trapezoidal para estimar la blabla en
las primeras 4 horas
este término suena muy intimidante lo de
sumatra peso ideal vamos a ver que no es
tan feo pero pero
tendrá que ser hasta el siguiente vídeo
me acabo de acordar que tengo que
recoger la ropa de la lavandería antes
de que cierren y la señora es súper
puntual con eso nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo y continuaremos con los
otros incisos hasta luego